I'm just back from Odessa where I went
with the defense select committee the
Airaid Sirens went there was this
massive bombardment by Russia the
largest single attack in any one day
mercifully the city itself was spared
but you're absolutely right they are now
moving away from the battlefield where
they're losing onto the infrastructure
hoping to freeze if you like uh the
Russia the the Ukrainian people out we
need to ask ourselves what more we can
actually do there was huge support for
the British effort absolutely everywhere
you went but ultimately they recognized
that if you want to actually defeat
Russia we need to do far far more in
preventing these attacks with more air
defense systems but also to flush Russia
out completely we cannot have this pause
and then for fighting roots to resume in
in the spring this needs to be concluded
now the international Collective effort
NATO still is sitting on his hands as
this formidable giant right next door
because Ukraine is not inside the tent
of NATO Britain is in is well placed see
what more can be done to make sure that
we can help the ukrainians at this
difficult time just really
just reading the telegraph this morning
about Brimstone missiles no official
confirmation but reports from the Daily
Telegraph today that Brimstone missiles
will be sent from the UK to the US tell
us about that yes I mean this is a
significant step do you remember those
discussions that we had about whether
things should be offensive or defensive
we are growing in our strength in our
confidence of what we need to do to
stand up to Russia not being spooked
that somehow if we give them a more
complex weapon system that it will then
ratchet out of control so I'm really
pleased that we're looking at this
weight but it can't just be Britain what
I noticed there was many other countries
are not doing as much as us and they're
burning through this ammunition at a
colossal rate so it begs the question of
how much more internationally that we
can provide great to see those
brimstones moving but also recognition
that these are dangerous times the world
is getting more dangerous not less this
isn't the time to cut our defense budget
so what are Brimstone missiles what do
they do they're very it's a it's a
medium sore to medium range can be
ground to to uh surface to surface but
all so normally air to surface they're
strapped onto our typhoons onto our
f-35s but there's now a way of you know
shooting them from the land themselves
but they're brilliant at targeting a
specific place they can go in through a
window into hey a building
um and they can also because of their
accuracy they can take out
um aspects of of the Russian military in
a way that some other assets haven't
been done in the past so this is a great
step forward How concerned are we about
um what's happening with the zaparitzia
and the atomic power plant that Russia
warning there could be a nuclear
accident this is exactly what Russia now
wants to do as I say it's losing on the
battlefield it's going to find cleverer
ways of expanding this this war so
hitting the uh the nuclear power
stations there's actually six plants
there as well that could set off an
atomic plume which would then drift
across that essentially would be Article
Five because it would affect the West as
we saw with Chernobyl but also there's a
dam just up the road from there as well
on the danipa river if they hit that
colossal damage too so again big
questions for the West as how we can
actually support because this isn't just
Ukraine's problem this is our problem
likewise with that grain that we spoke
about so many times when we went there
to the port just one fifth of the grain
is being able to get out why because
this is a Russian deal why is the bully
determining the deal in which boats
ships can leave territorial Waters from
Ukraine and move into international
waters again Britain is well placed to
be able to
revisit that deal itself push Russia
back they should have nothing to do with
this deal talk to me about energy
countries like Germany or the European
countries impacted by the fact that they
can't get their gas from Ukraine at the
moment as a result suggestions that
countries like that and others are
looking around and a lighting on China
how dangerous is it for countries to be
looking to China to get their power
again this is the more geopolitical
consequence of what's happening in
Ukraine I'm concerned that Russia will
deliberately see this it's attacked its
own power own cables and power supplies
North stream one I could easily see an
attack take place in one of the
connectors coming to Britain to actually
effectively turn our lights off as well
this is what they're going to do they
want to expand the war Putin wants to
advance This Way Beyond Ukraine itself
and then causing Peak countries like
Germany and so forth to then go begging
to countries like China which again
complicates the international picture
when we've got our own concerns with
that country as well yeah I suppose I'm
I'm perhaps alluding to the fact that
countries may be relying on China going
forward and and what your views and
projections are as far as that's
concerned another really big
conversation that we're in denial about
the fact that in our lifetimes as I've
said before you know China is going to
be so Advanced it's going to grow much
larger than the United States it will
dominate uh the international picture
but we haven't really come to terms with
how we manage that now China's Achilles
heel different to when we had a cold war
with with the Soviet Union is that it
requires an economic connections with
the rest of the world so we need to be
more robust in what are the rules and
regulations on trade and security for
which become we've become pretty timid
over the last decade or so okay it's
good to see you thanks so much Lou for
coming in thanks a lot